I feel like you guys work with such a
variety of people and we see how much
you change their lives but I wanna know
how much people change your lives and
you're working with them in each of
their stories oh my gosh every single
person we work with changes my life and
I think all of us is part of five I feel
like I wasn't there for my friends
they'll get older like attention and I'm
just like off in the corner these
expectations that you're holding on to
they're causing burdens in your life
when you hear someone else's story you
learn empathy you educate yourself on
their experience and with that empathy
of that education is when you start to
be able to walk in the world and be a
true ally to amplify their story and
their voice and you know like right now
in the world that's what we're seeing
people are waking up and hearing other
people's stories and they're educating
themselves or having empathy and they're
going out there and they're purchasing
and amplifying you know african-american
voices the voices of trans people it's
just a beautiful moment right now and
and so I learn every single time it's
the greatest gift of being a where I
outside of knowing these four
knuckleheads is that you know I say
knuckleheads we love is that you know
literally learning so much about other
people the best days are behind you
they're still in front of you
you were assured that this be kind
yourself in the first episode so what
are some ways that you think people can
be kind to themselves especially during
this well I think the first thing to do
is not to compare yourself to what
anybody else is doing that's a big thing
I mean when quarantine started I mean
like I was one of those people who I was
like where's everybody getting this
energy from to do tick-tocks to dance to
do everything because I was in my sweats
every day and so you have to give that
place of being like you know what it's
okay if I'm meeting time to process
what's happening in the world a little
differently or a little bit longer than
someone else and then in the morning
time when you wake up before you do
anything you know I try to practice
before I pick up my phone I go into the
mirror wash my face brush my teeth and
instead of focusing on something that I
don't like about myself trying to focus
on something I do and it just starts
your day off with the intention of
loving yourself and being kind here so
rather than going on to the world and
seeing what everyone else is doing and
focusing on the rest of the world
start here first that you can be better
out in the world my congregation they
came out this year I felt guilty I
wasn't able to come out until much later
in life
would you ever tell that kid they didn't
come out soon enough you know so why do
you tell yourself that I mean hear that
how much did you guys like working in
Philadelphia and how much do you feel
like that location really impacted the
show for this exam
I loved Philadelphia it's a really
important history or a city I never got
to live in it as far as American streets
concerned a really nice part to that
this season was getting introduced to
Walter the dog Antony how fun was it
having Walter in the house we loved well
obviously I welcome all dogs of all
colors shapes sizes and temperaments but
Walter was was a sweetie he did scare
ten a little bit ten yeah I was the one
that would touch
I was scared of Walter so you need
qualms in like little dogs you guys
aren't intimidated by but as soon as
they reach like a certain height you
guys get like a little uncomfortable
that's why both of my babies are tiny
Walter is a sweetheart he's a little
wackadoo of a of a rescue pup